[Music]
[Applause]
you know we talk about jimmy garoppolo
all he does is win all albert breer does
is report he is the monday morning
quarterback and he joins us on the
program first hour of the show we had a
poll question
who got the better end of yesterday the
niners or jimmy garoppolo
i'd say
that's a good question i think the
niners because they believe they've got
a team that should compete for a
championship this year and they think
they're gonna have the best defense in
the league
um as long as a couple things happen
along their offensive line they should
have one of the best run games in the
league
and so they've got the best situation i
think for a quarterback you could argue
in all football like for any quarterback
to step into
and so you know i think having insurance
at that position if trey lance gets hurt
and there's a lot to this right like but
if trey lance gets hurt having insurance
that position
um with a guy who's gotten you to the
nfc title game two of the last three
years into a super bowl and maybe like
one throw away from winning a
championship i think creates a great
situation because you've got the ceiling
there now with trey lance and what they
believe trey lance can be in time
and you've also got the safety net of
jimmy garoppolo
i just wonder though how does this help
trey lance if you're trying to you know
it's his team we've been told it's his
team but it's sort of your team now well
so
help me understand that yeah i think
it's probably important to take
everybody through how this happened
first right so
i think the niners were legitimately
surprised that they couldn't find a
suitor for jimmy garoppolo like they
think that he's better than a lot of
starting quarterbacks in the nfl right
and
so like i think over the last few weeks
it was how do we think about this
creatively
and obviously part of it had to be
approaching jimmy garoppolo about it and
saying if we can't find the right
situation for you out there
would you be open to coming back okay
and then it's talking to trey lance
which they did ahead of the the the
decision it's talking to the other
leaders of the team and my understanding
is a big part of those talks was making
it abundantly clear to everybody trey
lance is our starter we're gonna stick
through
we're gonna stick with trey lance
through any inevitable bumps that we
might hit so they felt like they had to
establish that with everybody and this
part's a really key part jimmy garoppolo
had to be willing to come back making
less than trey lance was the average on
trey lance's contract is over 8 million
dollars
so one of the things that was made
really clear to jimmy was if we're going
to bring you back your base pay permit
like and this is a hugely important from
an optics standpoint has to be less
than what trey lance is making
and that took some i mean i think that
took some pride swallowing from jimmy
because the number on his contract it
wasn't guaranteed but was 24.2 million
dollars
so
he was going to have to go to less than
a third of what he was making to get
underneath what trey lance was making
and jimmy was willing to do that
now why would you do that if you're
jimmy
because there's a possibility over the
next six or seven weeks
that a job opens up somewhere else that
someone falls on their face that someone
gets hurt and now because you've got the
no trade clause you can sort of control
your destination if the niners want to
trade you it allows the niners to kind
of keep that asset alive for the next
two months it gives the niners great
depth at the position
and oh by the way like
to get trade lands going they're going
to have to play him a little bit
differently they can't run the
conventional shanahan offense like
they're going to have to do some
creative things with him as a runner and
there's some risks that's associated
with that so if jimmy gets in because
trey gets nicked up
and plays for two or three games
if you're talking about like this from a
long-term perspective for jimmy
garoppolo and the goal is to become
someone's starter in 2023
is there a situation out there that's
better for him personally
to really shine in and look great in
than the one san francisco is presenting
him an offense he knows teammates he
knows really good talent around him so
i think you have to add all those things
up and i think this would be different
if there was like a clear-cut suitor for
for jimmy garoppolo out there but
because of the timing of the shoulder
surgery
that never really that that never really
materialized and so it left them in this
position where they had to do something
creative and again like i think the keys
are here jimmy's making less than tray
this doesn't happen unless jimmy's
willing to take less than tray and base
pay
and it's been made clear not just of
jimmy and trey but also to the other
leaders in the team the guys like fred
warner and nick bosa
and um
and devo samuel and trent williams it
made it clear to all those guys that
trey lance is our guy and absent injury
we plan on riding through any sort of
bumps with him how many
quarterbacks starting quarterbacks are
not as good as jimmy garoppolo in your
opinion or maybe the niners opinion if
if you even know that
i mean without going through all 32 i
mean what would you say 10 maybe
at least right
okay i mean i i don't know i don't hold
jimmy garoppolo in high regard i never
have i think he's a good quarterback and
he's a good story
i just i mean wait but if we go through
it right like is he better than jameis
winston goff in detroit winston in
new orleans baker mayfield he's taking
mayfield and carolina seattle
um you know i
look i think you can find i think you
can find ten okay like legitimately
where
for today for right now you'd rather
have jimmy garoppolo would you rather
have jimmy garoppolo than zach wilson
right now
no
no but just for one just in a one-off
situation not for like the next 10 years
in a one-off situation
i don't i don't know would you rather
have jimmy than jalen hurts would you
rather have jimmy than carson wentz
that one would be close
so but carson wentz can be better than
jimmy garoppolo and and that's the thing
is like i i do think that that's a piece
of this too dan right like
so like but to me albert it's about
fourth quarter
right you know quarterbacks have numbers
but you
who what are your numbers when you have
to have numbers when it's the fourth
quarter when it's right two minutes to
go
and that's where jimmy falls into
a different category
how many guys are like that though there
aren't that many
well but if i'm paying i'm with you i'm
with you on what you're saying like what
you're saying is and i think this is
what separates like like good from great
at that position right yeah it's third
and long it's down by two touchdowns
it's fourth quarter like that's what
separates good from great but how many
guys like pass that test there aren't
that many right no but but we hold him
in that high regard of all he does is
win
well
okay
does he win it or is he part of the
patriots and the niners who are very
good teams he's had great situations
that's okay
that's fair i mean he's played for josh
mcdaniels and kyle shannon yes that
gives you a head start you know that's
your cheat sheet but then i go to lamar
jackson lamar jackson has one of the
best winning percentages of all time one
of the top five winning percentages of
all time
but it feels like there's something
that's still there that's missing at
least for me like i don't i don't know
where the ravens stand with lamar
jackson and does he look at desean
watson and go well he got 230 guaranteed
i deserve more than that i haven't been
on a you know
you know in the news for anything other
than playing football here so help me
understand what happens next with lamar
jackson and the ravens i think there's
an intense round of negotiations over
the next 10 days that nobody hears about
because trust has been so important in
this thing and the ravens have worked so
hard to keep that that circle
um that they that they've involved in
this
like tight and it's it's they're not
very many people that know
um there are a lot of people out there
that think they know but there aren't
very many people that actually know
what's happening because the ravens have
worked to keep that
circle tight because they know how
important trust is
to lamar jackson i think part of the
issue with lamar that you're getting to
is are you comfortable
a playing that style right because if
you have lamar you're signing up to play
a certain style of football right are
you comfortable playing that style
and then b are you comfortable that he's
going to stay healthy doing it and last
year was the first time that he got hurt
like doing it you know
i think the answer for the ravens
in both departments is yes my
understanding is he put on i think like
about 15 pounds of muscle in the
offseason because of what happened last
year like you can see it in the pictures
right like he looks bigger and thicker
um so i think the ravens the answer is
yes on both counts and i think they're
willing to do this my understanding is
last year
they matched the number that josh allen
got they offered him 43 million per so i
don't think the raw dollars are the
question i think the guarantee structure
is the question okay and
like i thought it was interesting do you
know the one owner that came out when
deshawn signed his deal do you know who
the one owner who came out against what
jimmy haslam did was
[Laughter]
if lamar jackson was under contract you
wouldn't have heard from steve right so
i like i think that the unique thing
about lamar is
so i feel like all these guys like the
goal for the teams and the reason why
teams i think have been able to like the
reason why teams were able to not make
kirk cousins the new standard when he
signed his fully guaranteed deal
and why
some teams haven't had to go where the
the browns went with deshaun watson
i feel like most players have like a
dollar figure that they can't say no to
right and i remember having like a long
time executive say to me about these
sorts of negotiations our job is to find
that number right our job is not to like
go to where they want to go our job is
to find the number they can't say no to
where all the other stuff that they want
sort of starts to melt away right
and i think that that's like lamar's a
different dude like i don't know that
lamar is
caught up in like i want this number or
that number and if we get here i'm okay
like i think that's what's hard about
this one is like maybe he doesn't have
that number he can't say no to he's like
i just want what i want and if i don't
get it then you know fine i'll play the
contract out
and he's willing to take that risk he's
just he's wired differently you know so
like i don't i don't know that like
lamar's the guy that's gonna just like
look at it and say well this contract
guarantees me 120 million dollars and
that's good enough you know what i mean
like i i don't know that he's that guy
and i think we've seen it like right
like we've seen the way he operates like
he does things a different way he
carries himself a different way it's
part of what makes him great you know
and
like that's the best explanation i can
come up with again because that circle
has been so tight for why we are what we
are always great to talk to you you make
us smarter thank you albert all right
thanks dan that's albert breer he is the
monday morning quarterback